a lot of guys were asking for our
opinions on andrew tate so we're going
to react to a few of his clips and stay
tuned to the end for our opinions on him
what's your thought on uh islam and
everything because i know in the quran
and stuff like you could have up to four
wives and stuff so
i've seen you talk about it a little bit
but i would like to know like what you
think about it
i think it's the last religion on the
planet
you know that's the right religion i
think it's the last religion so if it's
the last true religion on the planet
then it has to be the correct one
because i don't think is it the last one
it's the last position because no other
religion has boundaries which they
enforce
if you stand if you will tolerate
everything then you stand for nothing if
your book says x but you refuse to say
the book says this i'm sick to what the
book says
doesn't matter what the subject is right
i don't want to gusband i think
if you're a christian
99 christians are ignoring every single
rule inside the bible okay everyone
should interpret the bible you're saying
like they like pick and choose what they
want to oh yeah they'll go
and say i interpret it differently i
believe in god but you know i don't
believe in that part that's not what the
book says doesn't seem it doesn't say
ignore half of me it says follow me only
muslims follow their book no true no
true so they're the last religion yeah
who gives a [ __ ] christians come and say
i'm a christian you know give a [ __ ] you
ignore the bible well isn't there a lot
of muslims that don't follow the quran
too i'm sure there's i'm sure there's a
lot muslims who don't completely follow
the quran but i'm saying that if you
were to go out there and try and find
muslims who live true to the quran
completely you can find them yeah you
ain't going to find this i think you can
find christians no you won't yeah
i mean
no different any religion but like dude
you're not going to find a muslim
that's right a woman that's a muslim
that's
put me in any church give me the hot
church there's muslims out there i'm
sure there are but i'm saying he's the
point he's making is you can find a
bunch of women who adhere to islam who
are still virgin to the age of 25
waiting for them umbrage marriage oh
yeah you will not find that under
christianity
yeah you can find a couple but you're
right there's probably more muslims that
follow christians christians there's
more devout muslims than devout
christians christianity has no power
left it's it's a power even the pope is
up here talking about and i i want to
make this very very clear i'm not i'm
not an auntie anything i'm a homophobic
i'm talking about what the book says if
the book says man and women lay together
and then the pope is going to stand up
now and saying that you can be a gay
preacher
the book doesn't mean anything now so
the whole religion doesn't mean anything
so the rules don't mean anything if
you're tolerant of everything you stand
for nothing the problem is with religion
is that naturally needs to be intolerant
for a religion to be a religion which is
respected it needs to be intolerant of
certain things you can't say we're a
religion which tolerates everything now
you have no belief systems when was that
book written you know
completely but the world evolves
completely so christianity has evolved
into nothing
islam hasn't this is the point i'm
making the point i'm making is if you're
going to throw your own rules away you
can't stand up and say this is a
religion these are our doctrines but we
tolerate everything and we don't punish
anyone for anything and none of it
really matters are you a christian well
the [ __ ] is it oh the world's a
christian lord stars are christians who
give it doesn't mean anything it's
different with islam with islam you
can't get away with it even if you're
saying that there's some [ __ ] etc etc
fine that's cool but people don't stand
up and openly disrespect islam oh hell
no because they're afraid
so once again if you don't have rule
systems and doctrines and beliefs and
prophets which people are afraid to mock
are you even a religion people won't
disrespect islam nobody will disrespect
it because they're scared
even in a christian country what do you
want what do you mean by disrespect i
mean disrespect it say something
disrespect it you could walk around if
you could wear a t-shirt saying jesus is
gay
right here in croatia christian country
and you will make it out the country
alive i dare you to do the same thing
with the islamic prophet dare you to do
the same thing you would make out of a
christian country alive an islamic
country alive even in christian
countries you are not safe to do that
you do not disrespect their beliefs yeah
disrespecting our lives no you don't do
that you don't nobody doesn't so what
i'm saying
if they're the last religion on earth
that people are afraid to disrespect if
their god is the last god on earth that
people are afraid to disrespect and he's
the only god that matters if every other
god can be mocked laughed at put in
video games [ __ ] shot at [ __ ] dressed
up gay on tv shows
[ __ ] what kind of religion is that
it's a joke
don't take that lightly what we don't do
we are not advocating or promoting
harassment or violence or anything like
that we will intellectually academically
refute them but we don't take that
lightly bro
yeah 100
my uh my question for andrew tate is
okay why aren't you muslim then you say
it's the last religion on earth it must
be the truth must be correct follow it
follow it you know what the book says
the book says that if you believe and do
good deeds and so on and so forth you'll
be rewarded with heaven but if you
reject
then where are you gonna go and if you
truly believe what you're saying in this
video why aren't you a muslim because if
you understand the full implications of
what everything you're saying actually
means and you're not just doing it for
sure or whatever
then you should understand that you as
an individual right now who's claiming
islam is the truth but won't practice it
people like that are doomed for help so
just accept islam be a muslim implement
it into your life you'll be happy
insha'allah you will genuinely be happy
and content in your life i um i i think
it's i think the guy's not boyfriend i
don't know his name but the boy has
pushed back on kind of what was being
said i think that was fair for sure but
like you were saying fired we don't
tolerate disrespect we might deal with
it in a in a kind
and you know genuine manner but we will
still deal with it right not everyone's
gonna go at you with the pit some people
will
um not that less we're supposed to do
we're not actually we're actually not
supposed to do that stuff the state is
supposed to deal with these people um
it's for muslims like us you know we go
we approach these people we talk to them
and we just humiliate them
intellectually then
this will be it
but
andrew himself has said a lot of things
that are actually on islamic or maybe
even islamophobic some people might say
this was probably a while ago but he
said that the nakab the face covering
for the women is dehumanizing what the
hell is that
right maybe he changed his mind on it
he's also supported tommy robinson who's
a clearer
in broad daylight islamophobic person
right
he's uh he's misunderstood islam above
versus where it says you know to um
unalive the unbelievers and so on and so
forth
i think that i shall allah he should get
on a muslim podcast with another muslim
talk about islam and this is an
invitation for andrew to come to islam
if you truly believe what you said in
that video just become a muslim
and i i generally want to ask them this
too like why are you speaking so much
about islam and muslims and one true
religion
and if it's clear to you then why are
you not accepting it and this this kind
of leads into another segway we want to
save to the end of this stream about a
lot of influencers and youtubers and
celebrities talking really well about
islam but they use it maybe perhaps and
allah knows their intention best but to
gain a following rather than sincerity
because if it was sincere you would have
done it already how many people do you
think except islam every single day and
they don't even make a video about it
bro so many of course we see mashallah
so many brothers and sisters doing
revert stories and all this type of
stuff but how many do you think don't
even make a video because they don't
even care about making a video about it
and yeah i was gonna say when he was
talking about
that if you go through like let's say
one of these like countries that are
muslim dominated could wear a shirt that
says
anything about any of the prophets peace
and blessings be upon all of them
you probably won't make it out of it
you know like it's not just the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
it's also jesus it's also moses
it's also isaac it's also abraham
it's all of the prophets peace and
blessings be upon all of them and that's
like that's what we hold very dearly you
know we respect them very dearly to
where it's like if anyone disrespects as
a yo yo how are you gonna respect
someone
who brought down
direct revelation
who was a guide for humanity
like who are you who are you who are you
to disrespect someone of this nature of
this um i want to say this level but we
can't even
can't even idolize
the prophets peace and listen to people
on all of them
so i just want to put let me point that
out
all right let's go right back in islam
fixes a lot of the problems that men are
currently facing the problems we're
discussing on this show islam fixes all
of them
right that's the first thing about islam
and i'm not a muslim right if i had to
choose a religion i would because i live
in an orthodox christian country i go to
the orthodox christian church i donate
twenty thousand dollars a month to the
church in the country
the church the church in romania is very
powerful and i like having church
friends so i give them a lot of money
right so i guess i'm an orthodox
christian but
if i had to bet on one religion as if i
were betting on the stock market for the
future you have to bet on islam
because muslims are intolerant
and i'm not saying that disrespectfully
because if you're tolerant of everything
then you stand for nothing but
christians are so tolerant now you don't
believe it they have gay pastors that
i'm not even anti-gay but if the book
says don't have like what yeah what do
you believe in
if you're tall if you're tolerant of
everything you stand for nothing
i can walk through
london with a t-shirt saying jesus is
gay and nothing will happen to me if i
did the same thing with the islamic
prophet i'd be dead before i got to the
industry boom
that's how much they believe and respect
and i respect people who stick up for
what they believe in yeah it's not about
me believing in it i respect them
because they they believe and they will
defend muslims the only people who will
defend their religion they will defend
their beliefs they refuse to be mocked
they refuse to be insulted and i respect
that about them i respect that that's an
amazing thing about them right and the
third point is and i've been all around
the world
some of the best countries in the world
today are the first world muslim nations
yeah qatar you can go to qatar you can
fall asleep with a million dollars on
your lap in the middle of the street
nothing's gonna happen saudi arabia you
don't go to saudi nothing will happen
you can go dubai uae nothing so they
leave their cars parked with the keys
inside it's so safe wow it's it's so
safe women everyone's married every
woman obeys her husband every single
woman has four five six kids big
families all the things we're talking
about all the problems we have here
right they've got none of that none of
it because of islam islam keeps society
in the role where women obey their men
women have children women have big
families women are exceptionally happy
to do so yes before before some western
girl comes in here and runs their mouth
the islamic women are happier than any
you're going to see in the club tonight
they're very true they're happy society
is functioning their population is
growing because in most western
countries the population is declining
yeah
talking about it today i'm sorry
one kid doesn't work it doesn't work
right do you two people need to have 3.1
kids because people die right people die
prematurely blah blah blah
so we have population problems in the
west have none of the population
problems society is functioning and
that's that's what society is society is
society starts at the smallest possible
group you have families and families
make a street and that street makes a
village and that village makes a town
that town makes a city and that city
makes a country so if it's broken at the
very fundamental level this family
level's broken that is broken the whole
way up yep yep and that's what's
happened in the west and the first world
islamic countries have none of those
problems all right all right so just to
give a little bit of a context this
video was taken about a year ago maybe
even more than that before the first
video that we played so this is kind of
an example of what we're talking about
when nami was saying why aren't you
muslim already like he's been saying
these same things the same jesus is
whatever allah
t-shirt the same argument it's almost
like a prepared or canned answer he's
like he said the same thing in the first
one he's saying the same thing now i get
it maybe you want to repeat your things
to make a point but it's bro actions
speak loud in the words
you're here using a cam girl business
and there's a lot of allegations that i
don't really want to get into because
it's there's nothing been like proven
yet
um in the court of law
um but again bro action speak loud in
the words if you want to be muslim
you're talking so good about islam why
are you not muslim
yeah and this is not about you know
questioning him as a person his
intention all that stuff allah adam
right because you're going to get people
that are like well you don't know what's
in his heart i don't i don't but as um
we judged by what was apparent when the
prophet was alive we judged by the
revelation that was being sent down and
by the process of what he said after he
passed away al-islam was
we judge based on what is apparent what
we see from the people and we compare it
to what allah and his messenger have
said so what i see from andrew tate
right now is he's saying a lot of things
he's getting on muslims good side and
that stuff now maybe what he's saying he
truly believes in but why is he not a
muslim yet that that's that's i think
the biggest question that he has to face
right now he said if he were to bet on a
religion like betting on the stock
market he would use islam but what he i
think he fails to understand is that he
does have to choose you are betting
right now you are a betting man and if
you're orthodox christian or whatever
you said you were because you donate
money to the church you're then
according to your own belief you are
making a bad bet a bad investment and if
you truly believe that islam is the best
bet well you do have to choose you have
to choose you have to bet because you're
going to die one day just like everybody
else
and we're all going to wake up some
people made the will have made the right
decision some people won't and we just
want to be from the people who make the
right decision inshallah
indeed so all this is a reminder man
where you at
why are you not a muslim yet
that's it bro there's no hate you know
he got on
brother brother eddie's uh the dean show
you know just like you
and eddie got brother numan ali khan
and they were going in and you know they
were talking about islam
and eddie asked a very genuine question
i thought it was kind of a rhetorical
question bro to be honest because i was
like why are you asking andrew tate if
he's read the quran because he's here
talking so much about islam why would
you even ask that like of course he has
you know what he had he answered he said
no i haven't yet it's been on my list
and again no no disrespect no nothing
but this was about a year of him saying
these things about if i had to bet on
one religion okay bro how are you going
to bet on something you haven't even
read the book but you're talking about
the book
so maybe maybe just you know before you
make any decision maybe before you make
any stance on it
read the quran understand the quran and
you know to me that's going to speak
more volumes than you talking about this
and anti this and pro this and again
guys we as muslims
do not support
woke women's movements i'm not going to
mention it now because you can say
anything get canceled today um by the
algorithm by the way not by the people
we don't care what people say but these
woke women's movements we don't support
it either so we agree with andrew tate
in that regard
but using that as an argument of islam
no
the main argument and premise for islam
being true
is
the the understanding about islam
theologically has nothing to do okay
yeah you can say things like okay we
support this cool this is this is
correct we're
pro family cool these are things that
that are our benefits of islam of course
but to prove that islam is true you
don't need to say these things
theologically fundamentally it's already
true there's other things that we have
discussed on this channel and you can
find in other youtube videos to prove
that it's true um and if you're sincere
about it bro
if you could do it then do it convert
the whole take speech channel islamic
i'm serious make a new banner islamic
text we are now a muslim channel
pro-islam this is haram
haram send her to saudi let her repeat
this
we need the will of god we need allah
listen i'm ready for the asteroid i've
had enough same no i am so ready there
are look there's 72 virgins awaiting me
just bring it on this is all done i've
had enough
i mean it's it's these same arguments
bro like it's the same or like you you
see people like sidemen and ksi saying
haram in kind of like a meme way like
everyone knows these terms they sell
stuff for allah cool
but bro to be to be riding the wave this
much without even actually being on
islam i don't know it's different
yeah and and really watching because we
used to have that this is haram thing as
like a sound bite for a time because it
was funny um looking back at it
it just seems like pure mockery if i'm
being completely honest
like everyone he's sitting there saying
things we actually believe in right we
believe in not about an asteroid that
was in the past with lu to allah and his
people things we actually believe in 70
verses and allah said he's mocking and
people are laughing this is a joke is it
sam a joke to you not all of a sudden
right right if you actually believe the
things you're preaching before if you
joke with that manner why didn't muslims
come and you know
do the things that you said they would
do to you if you disrespected islam
i think this is the message to the
muslims now all right this is not on
andrew tate i don't know what his
intentions are what's in his heart
that doesn't matter to me i we invite
him to islam right as muslims about the
end of the day
we can't be fools honestly let's not be
fools the the the new prince of the uk
quoted the quran and people are like oh
my god amazing joe biden quoted he said
insha allah and it was like oh my gosh
donald trump said that oh women want to
wear the burka the no club they want to
wear it why are we getting involved
people like oh my god you know these
people care about you none of these
people care about your religion unless
people care about your beliefs they
don't give a damn about it they really
don't the only people that care about
your beliefs are people with the same
belief muslims
right
just have a strong allegiance with your
muslim brothers and sisters let's unite
upon
the deen allah he says and hold on to
the rope of allah altogether and do not
become divided this is why because when
we're divided you have people like oh
look at this non-muslim oh look at that
muslim they're praising islam
you're falling for a trap habibi you're
falling for a trap
he's got you on his side now because he
said a few good words of islam he will
do nothing for islam he will do nothing
for you or for your life
a few words of encouragement motivation
about masculinity things you can get
from the prophet saw himself if you go
read the hadith of the prophet
and
you're you've contributed nothing and
you've had nothing contributed to your
life at the end of the day so please
don't be a fool and look at anyone who
preaches about islam who's not a muslim
and like idolize them muslims have a
problem the last thing i'm going to say
i'll let you guys go inshaallah muslims
have a problem with idolizing
non-muslims who preaches them why why is
that so significant they're not a muslim
but they're talking about how great it
is why is that significant
i don't understand that
i almost find it as cringe as when
people say oh look science has proved
this
and and it was already written in the
quran you know it's not synonymous
exactly what you're saying but it is it
is one to one in the sense that we
shouldn't need reinforcement by modern
science
which philosophically is something that
is you know
inductive not deductive right we
shouldn't need that to prove islam or
the quran or anything like that so yes
is it is it a dub sure but science can
be wrong and sciences has corrected and
changed a lot of things bro so using
these things to say something which is
timeless and then objectively true like
the quran it's not the same bro
yeah and angel before i let you go
brother i do want to mention i said this
a few times i want to say it again even
someone like andrew tate is even if in
his articulation of why islam is the
truth i think he's he's failing
he's committing a fallacy still and that
fallacy is he's still making himself the
measuring stick for what is true because
what did he say he didn't say that oh
there's prophecies in islam that's
undeniable that he gave this logical
argument that logical argument that
islam's understanding of god
theologically is the only one that's
philosophically compatible and that's
the only you know uh way we can deduce
which religion is right he said what
what did he say he said that if i were
to disrespect islam muslims would hold
their values to their hearts and and
attack you um there was a time when
christians did that the time when
christians ruled did that mean that at
that time they were right at that time
christianity was right there was a time
when christians were like that does that
mean that at that point christianity was
right no so he's making himself still
the measuring stick of truth that islam
agrees with things i already believe in
and they practice things i already
believe in therefore it must be true
you failed already you're making
yourself a measuring stick of truth
it doesn't work like that i think that's
the biggest problem that he has i think
and this is not an attack on him right
everyone has their own problems i have
my own struggles and stuff everyone does
but i think his is arrogance honestly i
i think sneko mentioned on podcast that
andrew tate recently said i'm god's
favorite
he even him saying i'm waiting for 72
virgins
bro
have you taken a covenant with god have
god came to you and revealed this and
not to you i'm being honest
if not then you're living a delusion and
you think you're going to be what go go
to heaven all that stuff and you're not
obeying the laws that even you said this
religion is from god must be true
i think it's problematic for yourself
and nobody else to be honest
yeah no
i agree i think we should leave it at
that
all right
we good to end off
yeah man alhamdulillah i agree with uh
rami
come on man like bro we're muslims at
the end of the day are we really that
foolish that
anyone just
just you know hypes up a little bit much
you know
talks a little bit good about islam and
all of a sudden they're like our new
muslim king or role model what
no bro no we have
role models we have those that we look
up to
and we try to model their actions their
behavior their conduct their integrity
their morale
it's not these these
i don't want to say bro but it's not
these
disbelievers bro you know and allah
knows best you know because at the end
of the day is it possible that andrew
tate is a muslim yes it's possible bro
no none of us are out here you know
trying to make duck feet or anything
we're not calling him a uh kofad or
anything like that what we're saying is
we judge by actions and if you haven't
become muslim you haven't even read the
quran yet bro like come on and you
you're still doing a lot of these things
i don't know bro i don't know
um again
this is not us reacting to the ban of
andrew tate from a lot of different
platforms this is not what this stream
was about um maybe we'll make a video on
that maybe we won't i don't really see a
need of um but he's been canceled on a
lot of things not much that we have to
say about that because i do know people
are going to ask us about that i don't
want to do a whole stream on that but
regarding this this whole cancer culture
and being you know off different
platforms
this is something that i hope you guys
are ready for you know we have we have a
youtuber that we got on a stream with a
few days ago or like two weeks ago i'm
not gonna mention the name because bro
that's how hot this this whole youtube
thing is right now like i don't even
think it's safe for us to mention the
name but he's been getting off left
right and center bro and i think this is
just the direction that you know things
are heading um we got to be vigilant
this is a message to the creators and
and especially if you have a muslim
channel islamic channel
be very careful bro
um i'm gonna have a one-to-one nasiha
with uh anustad that we got on the
podcast lately he's been going a little
bit too too into a lot of things overtly
um this is something that me rami and
angel have talked about lately too um
you know it's not worth getting
completely off the platform for and it's
a disclaimer too if you guys ever watch
this and you notice why are you guys not
talking about this why are you guys not
talking about that are you guys not
unapologetically muslim enough to talk
about this are you guys not unfiltered
enough to talk no it's not about that
bro believe me we agree with a lot of
the things that most muslims agree with
that have their head screwed on tight
we're not pro any of this modernity but
at the end of the day can we be the ones
fighting every single battle and and
having it highlighted all over our face
and and saying everything and risk
getting de-platform if that's the case
no it's not worth it so at the end of
the understand that we come from a place
of sincerity and love
we're not
modern woke
left muslims
none of that definitely not um but there
is a way you got to play this game if
you want to continue spreading the
message well
all right
and with that being said
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi